Superheroes are more prominent in pop culture
today than ever before.
Not only are comic books still going strong
as an art form, the comic book movie is also
the most popular genre in Hollywood.
More people now know facts about superheroes
as a result.
They know Wolverine and Deadpool have regenerative
healing factors, they know Spider-Man obtained
his powers after a radioactive spider bit
him, they know Superman is vulnerable to Kryptonite,
and they know Thor has a hammer that they
can't pronounce the name of properly - but
they don't know everything about these iconic
characters.
This video will run you through some lesser-known
facts about superheroes.
We hope you enjoy it!
And make sure you subscribe to our channel
join the notification squad to receive alerts
every time we upload something new!
Here are ten superhero facts that never crossed
your mind.
Superman Was Originally Meant To Be Evil
As far as superheroes go, Superman is not
only the most iconic of them all, he's also
the epitome of a shining beacon of good.
It takes a lot to make him breach his own
moral code and he is very rarely anything
other than righteous and noble - so it's hard
to believe that he was actually originally
intended to be a villain.
Jerry Siegel - one of the men who co-created
the Man of Steel - first envisaged the character
as "The Super-Man," who would have been a
bad guy with intentions to take over the whole
world and enslave humanity.
Fortunately, that character concept didn't
come into fruition - otherwise the entire
comic book scene would have been vastly different
today.
Spider-Man Once Operated As Four Different
Heroes
It's hard to imagine New York student Peter
Parker working under any other superhuman
guise than that of the iconic Spider-Man,
but at one point in his comic book history
he had no choice but to change his name and
image - and he actually used four different
identities to carry out his heroic escapades.
It happened when Spider-Man was being hunted
by the police, after Norman Osborn had framed
him for murder.
Parker donned four different costumes and
used four separate identities to go about
his duties - all of which had different weapons,
gadgets and abilities.
There was Hornet and Prodigy, who actually
acted as heroes, and Ricochet and Dusk, who
posed as criminals while actually doing heroic
things undercover in the criminal underbelly
of New York.
The four identities went on to be used by
other individuals after Spider-Man was able
to come out of hiding.
Wonder Woman Ran For President (Twice)
In a world in which tiny-hands himself, Mr.
Donald Trump, is causing controversy every
single day in his role as the President of
the United States of America, having a president
as morally sound as Wonder Woman is about
as far from being reality as one could possibly
imagine.
However, the fictional Amazonian heroine has
actually been seen running for president twice!
DC's utmost feminist icon took political action
on the 1972 cover of Gloria Steinem’s Ms.
Magazine, accompanied by the headline “Wonder
Woman for President!”
The cover of the original 1943 Wonder Woman
comic book featured the same scenario - and
all of this is in spite of the fact that Wonder
Woman isn't even American!
The aformentioned Mr. Trump would NOT approve
of that!
Wolverine Was Originally Meant To Be A Teenager
Since his first appearance back in 1974, Wolverine
has been depicted as a grizzled man - even
a very old one in certain stories - and that's
been an essential part of his character.
He's battle-hardened, war-torn, absolutely
no-nonsense, and often seemingly sick of the
world around him - but that could have been
very different if he'd been presented as was
originally intended.
Wolverine was actually meant to be a teenager!
The change to his character dynamic would
have been massive and, thankfully, Marvel
went with the Logan we know today.
Additionally, the plan was for him to only
have enhanced senses and an animalistic rage,
and not the healing factor and adamantium
claws he so famously possesses instead.
Aquaman's First Love Was A Dolphin
Aquaman takes a lot of abuse and is often
the source of laughs, in spite of the fact
that he's actually a very powerful and formidable
character - but it shouldn't really come as
a surprise, given some of his behaviour in
his earlier appearances.
One such example was that his first love was
actually a dolphin.
That's right, Aquaman was in love with a dolphin,
who went by the name "Nera" (so it's probably
no coincidence that Nera is a very similar
name to the woman who would later become his
wife).
The relationship with Nera ended when Aquaman
was jilted in favour of another dolphin - who
happened to be Aquaman's adopted brother.
It's something the character would never live
down and, in spite of the fact that he longer
seeks relationships with marine animals, he's
still a target for mockery.
Thor Once Helped Hitler
Thor is one of the only beings in the Marvel
universe worthy of wielding Mjolnir for a
reason.
He's heroic, brave, selfless and, as a general
rule, good.
But he once did something quite unspeakable
- even if he wasn't fully aware of what he
was doing; he helped Adolf Hitler.
In 1978's The Invaders #33, Captain America
and his team - the titular Invaders - discovered
Thor helping the infamous Führer and the
Nazis on their mission to kill Joseph Stalin.
When Thor initially failed to do slay Stalin,
Hitler even had the audacity to give him a
stern telling off! Thor ultimately realised
that he had made a terrible error in judgement
- isn't THAT an understatement? - but seeing
him working alongside arguably the most evil
man in real world history was quite the shock.
Ultimate Hulk Hates Freddie Prinze Jr.
The Marvel multivese consists of a near infinite
number of universes, meaning every Marvel
hero has counterparts in different timelines,
and for this particular entry we're moving
away from the classic 616 Universe and taking
you to Earth-1610 AKA the Ultimate Universe.
Back in 2002, the Ultimate version of Bruce
Banner was extremely upset to see that Betty
Ross was dating the actor Freddie Prinze Jr.
He was so upset, in fact, that the Hulk was
gunning for the actor and actually wanted
to find him and eat him!
The Avengers saved him in the end, but the
beef between Hulk and Freddie didn't end there
- it actually spread to the real world!
In 2014, the actor called out Hulk for a fight,
saying "Hulk had beef with me.
I've got a Hulk pool toy, so he don't look
so tough now.
Bring it, Hulk!"
He even went on to call out Hulk actor Mark
Ruffalo, saying "Who's playing the Hulk now?
Mark?
Gracie.
Jiu-jitsu.
Torrence Academy.
Let's go!"
Batman Was Inspired By 3 Iconic Characters
Batman AKA Bruce Wayne is one of DC's flagship
characters and one of the most iconic superheroes
in all of fiction.
He's pretty unique, so it's hard to imagine
that almost every aspect of the character
was heavily influenced by other people - both
real and fictional - but he actually was.
The Batman side of the character was heavily
influenced by Zorro, the Shadow and, believe
it or not, Dracula - and it's pretty clear
to see those influences when you actually
think about them.
Moreover, the name of his civilian identity
comes from two unlikely real world people
- Scottish folk hero Robert the Bruce, and
the United States Army general and statesman
Mad Anthony Wayne.
Captain America Turned Into A Werewolf
Like may other fictional universes, Marvel's
comic book universe has a supernatural element.
There are ghosts, vampires, zombies, demons
and indeed werewolves, for example - but you
probably already knew that.
What you might not know is that Marvel icon
Captain America actually became a werewolf
on one occasion!
It happened in 1992's Captain America #405,
after the evil Nightshade injected the hero
with her werewolf serum.
Despite the rather obvious physical change,
Cap's personality barely changed at all, and
he managed to escape, before stumbling inexplicably
across Wolverine.
Cap being a werewolf and Wolverine being in
a berserker rage was a recipe for a fight
- and that's exactly what the pair had.
Wolverine slashed at Wolf-Cap's shoulder,
then Cap embraced his new form and slashed
Wolverine's eye, before literally throwing
him away from the fight.
Deadpool Isn't Completely Indestructible
Deadpool is an incredibly popular character
who has now successfully transfered from the
pages of Marvel comic books to
the big screen.
Everyone knows he has an extremely impressive
healing factor, but the character's popularity
often results in fanboys and girls claiming
that he's completely indestructible as a result
of it - but the fact is he absolutely isn't.
Sure, he's come back from some serious injuries
and even from being reduced to a single speck
of bood, but he's been outright killed (or
at least effectively killed) on more than
one occasion in the past.
Most recently, in the Death of Deadpool arc,
he died along with everyone else when his
entire universe collided with the Ultimate
Universe.
In Age of Apocalypse, Nightcrawler decapitated
him and teleported his head away from his
body, rendering it unable to heal.
He was also reduced to a mushy pile of flesh
by Thanos, before the villain realised that
killing Deadpool actually did him a favour.
So, next time somebody tries to tell you that
Deadpool can't be beaten, feel free to prove
them wrong.
Thanks for watching our video about ten superhero
facts that never crossed your mind.
What other interesting superhero facts do
you know?
Have your say in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.